[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
give me three words to describe the
pretty message oh well I'll give you six
fantasy love escape glitz glamour and
fun okay
[Music]
three words to describe what the fans
are gonna see when they go to this show
exhilarating excitement over the top in
your face kick-ass fun okay that was
world more words than you asked for but
oh well well she gave us more words - so
restive around here Erika Jayne is
hitting the road it's her first
headlining tour ever
and only et got an invite inside one of
her final rehearsals what is the new
move that people are gonna walk out of
your show trying to recreate probably
when I jump off people's shoulders and
fall into a back bend
I don't something really good don't try
it out no the tour kicks off September
28th in New Jersey and due to demand is
expanding through the end of the year is
this the beginning of an era the
continuation of an era the end of an era
I am the Alpha and the Omega the
beginning and the end I am infinite
eternal can it get any better I don't
know this is you this is you yeah I like
a slow clap from the crowd behind us I'm
a clap for myself right there more
because blonde bombshell is always in
don't ever let anybody tell you it is
okay now here's the real question though
is it harder to dress Erica for tour or
housewives Housewives all day
still expect major fashion moments on
stage wardrobe changes 1 million percent
and you have to see how many we're doing
so you know I'm we're doing more than we
have done in the past I'm interested
[Music]
we did more reveal do what I'm joined
right it's a little bit racy how do you
get her out of a skin-tight cat suit
into something else quickly really
talented team of people I feel like that
fat cat and that YouTube video they
can't get through the door Jesus Marco
all right
gotta sneak in a house of course you do
I was waiting you're like when you're
like what happens is bring it come on
rice um you and Rinna stir it up a
little something-something I'm reporting
the facts we're here shooting the whole
cast is here rumor has it that one of
the cast members won't shoot with us
they won't do a group shot with us so
we're sequestered in a room was it LVP
what do you think I think it was LTP
that's what the internet detectives have
snuffed out will we see what led to that
play out on that decision
okay and does it have anything to do
with Doreen does anything not at the
Katori and I love to read my damn yeah
you know I have to say this because it's
really true for the first time in four
years I care about these women like I
have friendships with these women and I
don't like it
when I see them hurt and I don't like it
when I see some
okay so it's the real true genuine
connections you're no longer the ice
cream to these ways oh I'm the ice cream
I'm an iceberg the Alpha the Omega and
everything and everything in between
remember the iceberg suck the total
Titanic I think I'll have to leave it at
that the icebergs sunk the Titanic
marathon
[Music]